it was funny i said to uh a lot of the
guys
i work with a lot of younger guys
and i said to him not too long ago i
said
if you heard a story on cnn
five or eight years ago what would your
opinion be and they went
just that's the story like that's the
fact and right or something pertaining
to let's say to covet or some version of
that you know and i said what if you
heard that today
they said i'd have to look into it they
all went i'd have to go find out if
there was i work with a lot of young
people that have
really diverse opinions
that i don't know how to argue
but i respect that that's their opinion
jeremy smiling
i can you know my thing is can i say it
jeremy
i won't if you want me if you
he could say it himself if he wants to
jeremy sorry would you ask i asked can i
talk about like one of your opinions i'd
like to hear his take on it yeah do it
yeah jeremy's a flat earther uh-huh
i i
i
you know it's interesting about flat
earthers
i work with dr drew obviously very good
friends with dr drew and i think
flat earthers drive him nuts
they drive me they piss him off they
drive him nuts okay i love this guy he
doesn't drive me now and there's there's
a there's a few of those people out
there
um i'm not bothered by flat earth i'm
not bothered i love this guy he's
probably one of the most talented
smartest people i know yet
he doesn't believe in the globe
well i would
you know i would ask
that
it well
help me
understand why
jeremy
we we should have a dedicated episode to
this no i just want to give a couple one
that you listen to specifically that has
a podcast or something right that talks
about it and all the reasons he gives
for i just want to hear adam's take on
what you think so just tell them what
you think and then
we can have 10 episodes on flat earth
uh yeah uh
[ __ ] i don't know i just uh
i've always been um
you know i grew up the same way as
everyone like i knew
you know i took science classes and all
that stuff i just when that idea got
presented i never thought about it
before and then when i tried to think
about it it was just i don't know i
think it's interesting well okay let me
let me just chime in here jeremy right
yes
so
here's the question with a lot of a lot
of stuff because i've noticed this what
we would call conspiracy theorists if
you
look at a lot of conspiracy theorists
it's not the actual
subject flat earth or there weren't any
jews in either one of the twin towers
that came down or you know these kinds
weren't i didn't i've never heard them
never heard that you know is that why
they no no look
um
there are many theories about like no
jews being in that building on on 9 11.
ed asner
the late great asner thinks those two
buildings were taken down by the u.s
government
wow absolutely and there's many people
jeremy you don't do you think that
yeah i do oh so i didn't know those were
just synonymous jeremy you're making
you're making my point
what is
the earth being flat have to do with no
jews in either one of the towers on 911
and our own federal government being
responsible for wiring those buildings
to take them down to the ground those
are two different subjects right right
but
as i found and i found with ed asner
when i interviewed him as well
the commonality between the conspiracy
theorists is a sort of distrust and a
hate hatred for our government it's not
so much i think the earth is flat it's i
don't believe our [ __ ] government and
when they tell us something i reject it
so that's where the twin towers and the
flat earth
have an intersection but i didn't that's
like never going to you don't believe we
went to space either right i'm assuming
i think you never
no no no the moon landing yeah no no no
never got to get on board so it's an
overall
it's suspicion
and it's probably a dislike for our
government versus
i think but aren't some of these things
like the the globe is not a government
like i don't know that the i don't think
the world is round because of government
well an orthodoxy well first off the
government sent people the outer space
the government faked the moon landing
the government built the satellites and
sent them up so we could photograph the
earth from space so that you could see
it was around there's a there's a
connection
wow
so but but jeremy right hates
the government or mistrusts he hates the
government and his stepdad those are the
two
those are the through lines but here's
the thing because most people would
think that these are obvious simple
constructs
yet now that i know jeremy he's probably
he's incredibly bright he's incredibly
talented
he is so the the two thing like
it sounds silly some of these thoughts
sound silly but but from a bright person
where's jeremy on vaccines on covet
vaccines what do you think what do you
think i know where he's at
you want to know i offered him 50 000
cash he said no i gave him 60 not to do
it
no but howie yeah
what i was saying is sort of pattern so
going back to the beginning of this
conversation when i was studying covid
and i was like i see where these
patterns are going
i just sussed out jeremy for you did i
not absolutely that's amazing right he
said he's a flat earther i knew where he
was on vaccines and the twin towers
right in space right so
there's patterns to people
and that's what you're you're seeing
but he probably thinks the same thing of
us
yeah i'm sure i'm sure he does but what
i'm what i'm saying is is things don't
really exist in a vacuum even if you're
in outer space where no one can hear you
scream evidently
i i'm just saying
it's people get obsessed with you really
think the earth is flat it's not you
really think those twin towers were
wired by the government and just you
know blown up like a casino in vegas
that it out you know lived its use or
whatever and it's like
it's not so much that it's a general
gestalt of i don't trust
government
information and what
what is a what would be a norm what
would be convention so everyone is
saying get the vaccine get back to
normal
jeremy is saying not so fast
i don't trust general
convention and then this would then be a
universal thing that would be applied to
all facets of life so flat earth vaccine
twin towers all very different subjects
but from the same source it's all coming
through the same prism
and being processed the same way so
that's how you know where jeremy is
[Music]